[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: So today
what I'm going to try and do
is go through some of
the survey questions
that we asked you
last time at the end
and try to illustrate
some of the topics
and some of the issues
of behavioral economics
using short survey answers
and trying to give you
a better or more
precise overview of what
kinds of topics are we
going to talk about.
As you know, this
survey was anonymous.
Somebody was asking, do we need
ethical IRB approval for that?
We take ethical issues,
in fact, very seriously
in all of the studies
that we're doing.
The answer to that is, since
the survey was anonymous,
and there was no
personally-identifiable
information collected,
it's OK to do that,
in particular in
situations where
arguably nobody is
harmed from answering
those types of questions.
The surveys, you might say
that's not a particularly
rigorous experiment.
A survey, that's exactly right.
So the survey that we we're
asking, in some sense,
provides some
suggestive evidence
of some of the behavioral
issues are going on.
A lot of the evidence that
I'm going to show you in class
are much more rigorous in
terms of actual much more
rigorous experimentation
that's kind of hard for me
to do in a short survey.
So you think of these evidence
I'm showing you as suggestive.
And then I'm going to show
you more rigorous evidence
that those kinds of
phenomena, in fact, also
holding once you do
things more rigorously.
So now when you
think about how do
economists think
about human behavior,
there are broadly
three aspects in which
you can think about that.
The first one is--
or broadly speaking, we have
constrained optimization,
where people have a
utility function, which
is specifying in some
mathematical form of what
makes people happy.
There's stuff in the world,
consumption and so on, that
goes into the utility function.
You can eat apples,
bananas, and so on.
And essentially,
the more of those
you eat, usually
the happier you are,
which economists have construed
as a concept called utility.
Higher utility is good.
And it specifies what
makes people happy.
Now there are different
aspects to that.
You can think of this as there's
the instantaneous utility
function.
And I should have
said in recitation,
we're going to discuss a
review of utility maximization.
If you have taken
1401, 1403, 1404,
and are very familiar with
this kind of material,
you might want to skip
recitation this week.
Future recitations will
be much more general
and specific to the class.
So what makes people happy
is essentially two things.
One is there's an instantaneous
utility function, which
is kind of like at this moment
in time what makes you happy
or on a specific
day-- often it's
defined on a daily basis
or even yearly basis
at a specific period or moment
in time, what makes you happy.
That's the instantaneous
utility function.
And then there's time,
risk, and others--
these are like risk, time,
and social preferences.
So time preferences is
how do you aggregate over
time, today versus tomorrow,
two days, three days, four days,
five days from now?
How do you aggregate these up?
So you might be happy--
you might make a choice
today that makes you today
very happy.
But you regret it in
five days from now.
And the question is
how do you aggregate
these instantaneous
utility functions
into one big function?
Those are time preferences.
Risk preferences is when there's
risk involved, when things
are uncertain, so if
I offer you a lottery,
if you want to play the
lottery or the like,
if you take certain classes, if
you study for an exam or not,
these are often risky choices.
In a sense, you can do
one thing or another.
Often you don't know
what the outcome
might be in various choices
that you make in life.
And then often some people
are what we call risk averse,
to say they avoid risk.
And that affects their choices.
And then finally, as far
as social preferences,
you could say social
preferences in some sense
go into the instantaneous
utility function,
in a sense of that's just
another sort of argument
of that function.
Or you might say, in some
sense I care about myself.
And I care about others.
And so if I'm aggregating
my own instantaneous utility
and others' instantaneous
utility, [INAUDIBLE] larger
function overall.
But broadly speaking, one part
of people's utility constrained
optimization is the
utility function.
Second is people's beliefs.
This is how they believe--
what people believe
about their environment.
When you think about
purchasing things, that
would be not usually
prices, it would be
returns to certain investment.
If you take a class
versus another,
or if you take a
major versus another,
what does that lead to in
terms of your future earnings,
your happiness, and
so on and so forth?
And then one of that is
essentially your priors, what
do you think about the world?
And then how do you
update your information
once I provide you
with new information?
So there's like some prior
beliefs that you have.
I'll provide you
some new information.
And you update it to your
posterior beliefs overall.
And then when you think about
the utility maximization,
problem from a mathematical
perspective, you might say,
once I know your
preferences, and I
know your beliefs
or your information,
I have all the
information I need.
I can solve for the optimum.
And that's how
you should behave.
When in some sense, the whole
problem is solved for you.
So we are done.
But then even conditional
on that, people
seem to make choices
that don't quite
fit the classical
economics framework, which
is kind of how are people--
or the question
is, how do people
use utility functions
and beliefs to make
certain decisions?
And do we find certain
anomalies or deviations
from the perfect
utility maximization
in a sense of using
preferences and beliefs?
So there's different things
that some influences on behavior
aren't just about
utility and beliefs.
In particular, the issues
like-- as I talked a little bit
about last time, which are
frames, default and nudges,
and sort of heuristics.
That's to say the way I
present a problem to you
might affect your choices
greatly for given preferences
and for given information.
That is to say you might think
you like one thing or another.
And you have certain
information about the returns
to these choices.
But then the way I
present an information
or I set the
default, for example
for savings or other
choices, people
might decide
dramatically differently.
So now what I'm going to do is
essentially take each of these
items, essentially
first preferences,
the utility function,
second beliefs,
and then choices
and decision making,
and show you essentially how
using psychological insights
might be used to
improve people's--
to understanding their
decision making as a whole
or understand certain
choices that people make
and how essentially
psychological aspects might
affect people's behavior.
So the first thing I'm
going to talk about
is a social
preferences is like how
do people think about
themselves and others?
And much of classical economics
thinks that people are selfish.
They essentially care about
themselves and nobody else.
Is that a good assumption?
Or what do you think about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think you can think of it in
many ways that eventually leads
you to think [INAUDIBLE]
you can say that you value
[INAUDIBLE] other
people [INAUDIBLE]
caring about other
people and comparing
to caring about other people
because it makes you happy
somehow.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So one thing you're saying
is essentially it's actually
tricky to figure
out what's selfish
and what is not,
is in some sense,
if I'm nice to all of you, it
could be that I'm really nice.
It could be that I just
really care about evaluations
or whatever.
So in some sense,
it's hard to interpret
from people, what
they do, in terms
of understanding their motives.
That's actually a
very tricky question
in behavioral economics,
trying to figure out,
are people truly altruistic?
Or are they doing things for
others for ulterior motives?
I want to step back a little
bit and saying overall,
the assumption of selfishness
is actually a pretty good one.
In many situations, when you
think about people's choices,
usually the choices
affect people themselves.
When you think about
what kind of classes
do you choose, what
kind of profession
do you want to get into, whom
you want to marry and so on,
often that's a choice
that affects yourself.
These are individual choices.
People are selfish.
Of course, people are not
selfish in all respects.
But overall it's
actually mostly true.
It's actually a pretty good
assumption in many situations.
What I'm going to talk now
about is in some situations,
it's not a good assumption.
So we should amend or think
about this a little more
broadly.
And one way I think about this
is to think about charity.
2% of GDP is spent on charity.
I guess it was $373.3 billion in
2015, which is a lot of money.
So there's some
evidence that people
seem to be caring about
others in some way.
Now one way to think
about this is to say,
you have a utility function
that has as an argument,
other people's utility
or consumption.
So there's some
people who say, I'm
donating money to
somebody in Kenya.
I have a utility function that
says, this person in Kenya,
if that person has
higher consumption, that
makes me happier.
That's one way to
think about this.
But there's also a broader ways.
And you may call that pure
altruism in the sense of I'm
just caring about that person.
If that person does better,
that makes me happier.
But that's probably
not the whole story.
So what other
reasons might people
have to give or
be nice to others?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] warm glow
from others knowing you gave?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, so
warm glow-- can you say more?
What do you mean
exactly by that?
AUDIENCE: If other
people that you gave,
you can get a warm glow feeling
from people knowing that you
gave things to other people.
FRANK SCHILBACH: So you're
saying two things, I think.
One is warm glow, just
feeling good about updating
about yourself in some sense.
People call that
often self image
or the like, where
essentially just
you want to be a good person.
Somebody asks you,
would you like
to give money to somebody else?
It's not like you actually
care about this other person.
But you want to maintain your
image of being a good person.
And it makes you just
feel good about yourself.
You said also
something different,
which is you care a
lot about what others.
So one is about self-image, what
do you think about yourself.
I'm a good person.
I give to others.
And if somebody asked me,
I should probably give.
And you said
something else, which
is I care a lot about what
other people think about me.
And so usually we think of that
as called social image, which
is to say, I care a lot
about others' opinions.
And if other people think I'm
a nice person, giving money
helps with that.
What else?
What other motives do we have?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So that's a little bit,
in some sense, semantics,
in the sense of if I give
money to pay lower taxes,
in some sense, if I looked
at this more carefully,
it may look like-- and
I'm going to show you
some evidence of essentially
the fraction of money
that's donated to [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to split this up.
And there, some aspects
in that, for example,
if you donate money to
Harvard for a building,
it's not obvious that's
necessarily altruism
as opposed to you feel
really good about yourself
to have your name on a building,
if you have $100 million
or something that's
at your disposal.
So you're saying essentially
some behaviors that
may look altruistic, but
in fact, they're not,
in part because it's just
individual optimization.
So in some sense, that's
more like a misspecification,
a misunderstanding of people's
motives, which I think surely
is in some of what looks like
altruism, which in fact, it's
not.
There was-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] more
altruistic [INAUDIBLE]
altruistic societies
[INAUDIBLE] have access
to [INAUDIBLE] then you could
be acting altruistically,
but in a sense of trying to
ultimately optimize your own
[INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: So
if I can rephrase--
we're going to get
to this, in fact,
in a few lectures on the
social preferences, which
is to say if you
compare societies,
in certain societies, for
example, if people do things
like whaling or the
like-- essentially,
if you do occupations
where you need cooperation
to be successful in
your finding food
or the like, that might
lead to altruism, where
altruistic behavior people,
help each other not necessarily
because they like each other.
But essentially it's necessary
to be able to survive.
And then that might
lead to either just
cooperative behavior as a
whole, or perhaps to people
are, in fact, nicer
to each other.
So we will actually get to that.
And that's essentially
exactly as you say, sort
of an evolutionary perspective,
and saying depending
on what sort of the social the
incentives are for society,
depending on what kinds
of professions people do,
people might be nicer or
less nice to each other
because it's necessary to
survive or be rich and so on.
What else?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You might
have expectations
about whether other people
will reciprocate [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So there is essentially
reciprocity.
If I do something
really nice to you,
and then ask you
a favor in return,
you might not actually
want to do that.
But you feel so inclined because
I've been [INAUDIBLE] you.
It's a thing that
we do in society.
And reciprocity is
really important.
Quite related to
that is fairness.
in some sense, if
somebody does something,
or if somebody gets paid a
lot more than somebody else,
you might want to
share that with others,
not necessarily
because you want to.
But it's perceived as unfair.
And people are
uncomfortable with that.
Anything else?
Yes?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] stress.
So maybe when you
observe suffering,
you take it on as
your own suffering.
So when you act
altruistically, it's
not necessarily because you care
about these people directly.
But you now want to
alleviate your own suffering.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
So that's what economists
would refer to as the inequity
aversion, one way or the other,
essentially seeing inequality
or inequity makes
people uncomfortable.
And that comes in various forms.
One form of that would be, as
you say, in absolute terms,
look here, people, and this is--
I said a lot of poverty
and development economics.
Here is people who
are extremely poor.
It's either our
moral obligation,
or I just feel uncomfortable
seeing people suffering.
We should help them to
get over a certain--
up to a certain
standard of maybe
reducing or eradicating
absolute or extreme poverty.
There's a different version
of that, which is just to say,
inequality is just uncomfortable
and unfair overall.
We have, for example,
in the US people are
a lot richer than say in India.
Nevertheless you
might want to think
you would like to live in a fair
and just society, where people
at least have a reasonably
high living standards
that they live on.
And then it's either a
moral or other obligation.
And people might give
because it might just
feel uncomfortable to them.
I think we said
all of the things
that I have here mentioned.
And so there's various questions
on various motives on altruism
and why people give
and are nice to others.
Part of what we're
going to discuss
when we talk about
social preferences
is trying to disentangle
those different motives.
And there's a bunch of
different experiments
that people have run to
trying to learn about
why do people give?
What determines altruism?
What kinds of circumstances make
people become nicer to others?
Or if you wanted to increase
altruism, how would we do that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does caring
about others mean
the general population?
How would they look
at it as caring
about your friends or family?
[INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: I think
those are very much related.
There's a bit of a
question overall.
When you think about
your utility function,
usually it's defined
for individuals.
It's essentially you,
yourself, how are you doing?
There's other views,
where you say,
it's actually the
household as a whole.
So essentially everybody in
your household is a unit.
And then you
maximize as a whole.
There's a bunch of things about
within the household, conflict
and issues that arise.
And decision making
within households
might not be optimal.
But you can think of altruism as
narrowly defined about friends
and people that you love.
And presumably you have
like higher altruism
towards those individuals.
And then people who essentially
are further away, there's
less of that or
perhaps other motives.
These things are surely related.
But they're distinct.
I think when you think about
your parents or your family,
what do you do for
them, often there's
different motives
than when you--
for example,
reciprocity et cetera,
seems a lot more important
in some ways or perhaps
pure altruism, as opposed
to inequity aversion
or when you think about poor
people across the world.
But I think these things
are very much related.
And the question is, which
of those particular elements
are more important in
different settings?
So then the key questions
we're going to ask is--
one is what is the nature
of such social preferences,
i.e. the motivation to
help and hurt others?
We mentioned already
most of them.
And we're going to
try and understand
which of those are
important in which settings?
So one of them is
what determines
and why do people
give to others?
And a separate question--
so broadly speaking,
you can think of this as
like why are people nice?
And what determines-- to
others, and why are they
doing that-- or appear
nice, if you want.
And a second version is
called social influences.
How does the presence
of others affect
your behavior and your utility?
And then to say it might be that
you care a lot about others,
what other people think,
or you are very jealous,
and so on and so forth.
That's not about being nice.
That's just about your utility
might be deeply affected what
other people think about you.
They're going to talk a
little bit about things
like Facebook and Instagram,
et cetera, social media
in particular.
It might affect how do
you feel about yourself.
And social influences might
shape people's behavior.
So when you think about
then why are people nice--
and this is what you were saying
earlier, about when you think
about where do the nations go?
I was saying, 2% of GDP
is given to charity.
When you look at some
of those charities,
for some of the charities,
it seems pretty clear
that people do that because
they want to be nice to others.
For other charities,
perhaps not so much.
And some of the education
ones are essentially donations
to essentially the sponsor like
a quarterback at your school.
It's not clear that
this is altruism.
Other donations, if you
give for health or poverty,
I think that's pretty obvious.
Now what we did in
class is we-- so one way
to think about social
preference as a measure, that's
a very basic and coarse
way of doing that,
is what's called the
dictator game to measure
people's preferences.
And it's very simple.
And one of the questions
we asked you was,
here's if you get $10,
you could split it--
and it's a hypothetical
question in class,
actually in lecture
12 or something.
We're going to do this at least
at some point with real money.
But the question is,
if you had just $10,
what would you do with that $10?
How much would you
keep for yourself?
And how much would you
give to somebody else?
The other version that
we asked you was--
or there was two
versions of that.
One was the
recipient is informed
about the circumstances
of the decision.
The other one is the other
person might never notice.
The money is just
given anonymously.
How can we use that to--
what can we disentangle
potentially from those two
choices or options?
If people choose
differently in one and two,
what does that tell us?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] one,
they chose to split it,
that might be more
of a social thing
because they know that the
other person will know.
So they might worry that
[INAUDIBLE] too much.
But if they answer the
same for the current two,
then they're a little
bit more selfless
because let's say then they
would split [INAUDIBLE]
whether or not the
other person knows.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So in some way,
at least, you can
think of some form of pure
altruism, in some sense.
I would be very happy if you had
$10 more on your bank account,
even if you never knew.
There's no reciprocity.
There's no you
knowing or learning
about what I did or didn't do.
It's just like I'd be happier
if you had more money.
And therefore I'm
giving it to you.
Of course, there's
things like self-image
and so on, are hard to rule out.
In some sense maybe it's
not like I'm actually
happy about you.
I'm just happy about be about
me being happy about you.
So there's tricky
issues about that.
But it's getting close to
a form of pure altruism.
If instead, you learn
about that either I
explicitly-- it was
me who gave you money,
or at least there was
somebody else doing it,
then that's much more
about the person who
cares about where the money
is coming from and so on.
That tells you more
about social motives
potentially about how
the other person feels
when they get money, how
others were treating them,
or perhaps how I feel when the
other person gets it and so on.
Is there a question?
No.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I don't
agree that it would necessarily
have to be about
repetition [INAUDIBLE]..
It could simply be
about promoting the idea
of getting [INAUDIBLE].
So if a person
[INAUDIBLE] it doesn't
serve to promote the
idea [INAUDIBLE]..
But if it did, the person did
know that somebody else was
going to give them
money, it would
serve to [INAUDIBLE]
even if-- they
could be equally selfless even
if [INAUDIBLE] your intentions
are [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: So just to
clarify, so in number two,
I think what I'm
saying is that's pretty
close to pure altruism.
In number one, I'm saying
there's other forces at play.
One of them is about people
care about what others do.
You were saying in some
sense it's a version of that
and saying, if it promotes
altruism, in some sense,
if I give you money,
and you learn about
that I give you
money, and the hope
is that you'll give money to
others, in some sense you would
only do that if you care about
others one way or the other,
or if you learn something
from those kinds of actions.
That's all good.
I think I'm just
saying there's--
so those kinds of
experiments will
help us disentangle potentially
different motives for giving.
This is a whole course.
And you can't rule out
all sorts of things.
But it's clear
that in some sense,
there is something
different, which
has to do with people
caring about others one way
or the other in some way.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I actually
did have a question.
Do you think the
results could change
if we gave a larger
sum of money,
like $500 or $1,000
or something?
Because with $10, the
difference between getting $5
and getting $10 isn't
going to be big.
That's the difference
between having a nice $5
and being able to get
four bags of chips
versus two bags of chips.
So if you do it with
$1,000, the difference
between $500 and $1,000 could
be the difference between--
something larger, like $500
would maybe pay for [INAUDIBLE]
a while.
But with $1,000, you could maybe
buy a small car or something
with it.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Yes, understood.
So there's only
two questions here.
One is I'm asking you
hypothetical questions.
And you might say
all sorts of things.
But once I'm actually
putting down money and say,
here's actually $10, how
are you going to behave?
So what we're going
to do in class,
we're going to have some
hypothetical choices.
Then we have some
real choices and going
to look at how that's different.
In general people choose
actually pretty similar
and hypothetical
to real choices.
Then what we will not be able
to answer in class is how would
you choose if I give you $500?
Because I'd be poor
at the end of class.
However, there have
been some experiments
with bankers and rich
people and so on,
where actually they
gave people $1,000.
And what you see overall is
that people's giving behavior
in those kinds of
experiments actually
is quite similar
to smaller sums.
I think there may
be some differences.
And I think there's a huge
difference potentially
in particular when you think
about poverty in developing--
or giving in
developing countries.
There's a huge
difference potentially
whether you give people
large sums of money,
and that could
change their lives,
and people could invest
and so on and so forth,
as opposed to very small amounts
or even repeated small amounts.
If they give you $5 every
few days for quite a while,
that might actually
not change things
that much because every small
thing feels really small.
But instead, if I give
you $1,000 right away,
you might invest and try to
have a better life and so on.
So in that sense, I think
that's potentially different.
When you think about
these kinds of experiments
actually look quite similar
in the behavior at least
in lab games.
So now how much do people give?
So the strict
version, just to be
clear in terms of
the standard model,
would say, people should
give exactly zero.
If you care only
about yourself, why
would you give money to others?
You just keep everything.
Usually subjects
give about $2 to $3.
The average giving in class
with about $3 in the first case
and $2 in the second case.
So in some sense,
it seems essentially
that when the person knows
about the circumstances--
so something that's valued
more either being it
signals altruism, or just the
other person might be happier,
and so we appreciate
that in some way.
And so here is what
this looks like.
You can see the distribution.
A lot of people give
either $0 or $5.
There's a few of you who
would give everything.
That's very nice.
There I do wonder if it's
actually if you gave--
it was actually 10
real dollars, would you
really follow through?
But surely there are
some really nice people.
There's some issues
with those kinds
of games in a sense
of I'm eliciting
your behavior in terms
of what would you
do if I gave you $10
with some other student
or some other person
that's fairly rich?
You could see some people
actually saying, I'm giving $0.
And instead I'm donating the
money to somebody in Kenya.
It would look in the lab
as if I was really selfish.
But in fact, I'm
actually altruistic.
So there's issues with these
kinds of lab experiments.
But in general, I think people's
behavior in these lab games
is fairly predictive
of real world things
that we care about.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about the
order in which these questions
were asked because I
remember on the survey we
had the question on the
left being asked first.
And I think my thought process
would have been different
if I had been asked the
questions in the reverse order.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Yes, absolutely.
So I think in an
actual experiment
that I or others would
run, this would be
randomized what the order is.
And then they can test
for that directly.
Or what you would do, is
you randomize across people.
So some people get one question.
And people will get the others.
We haven't done that in part
just because otherwise we
would have had to send
you different links.
And it was already
chaotic enough
to send you one
link, which seems
to be the most we can handle.
But usually what
you would do, is
essentially you would
randomize the order
and then be able to do that.
My guess is that broadly
speaking the results
would be similar qualitatively.
There might be some
small differences
in terms of the exact numbers.
And surely the order of those
kinds of questions often
matters, which in some sense
goes to we have a number--
the third aspect
of choice, where
if you think about in
then the classical model,
the order should
surely not matter.
Essentially I'm giving
you some choices.
You have a utility function.
You have beliefs.
And now just you'd be done.
The order is
completely irrelevant.
But it turns out that
order effects often in fact
are quite important,
in an experiments,
and I think in the
real world as well.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] think
about how too much altruism may
be [INAUDIBLE] if someone gave
me $5 [INAUDIBLE] when you gave
$10, they might think
they're really weird or not
[INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK SCHILBACH: No,
that's a great question.
In fact, we do--
so a lot of these
experiments, and what
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about is as well,
a lot of the
experimental evidence
that's been
collected so far, has
been collected in rich
countries and Western countries,
industrialized countries,
rich and educated people.
And the acronym for that is
WEIRD, which is essentially--
think of a lot of
experiments are
done with mostly college
students and rich universities
in the world.
And their behavior
might not be as--
so in some sense,
the hope is that we
find universal
characteristics or parameters
of people's behavior.
But it's not unreasonable to
think that in other societies,
people behave quite differently.
And for example, one thing that
we find in India, in part--
we do these kinds of
games with people.
And there, sometimes people
would say, if I gave too much,
or if somebody else--
often we have these
games, where it's not just
one choice, but another choice.
And if somebody, for example,
offers you too much money,
the other person reacts
and says, this is weird.
I can't accept this money,
because otherwise I would
owe them some debt or the like.
So there's these kinds of
behaviors, where in some sense,
it's more complicated
because of other reciprocity
or other reasons.
In China and other
countries, there's
a clearer culture
of reciprocity,
that people are fairly
careful of, for example,
on whom to invite and
so on and so forth,
and whom to accept
presents and so
on from because you
know in some sense,
you have to reciprocate
at some point.
And if you're not able to
do that, that's very bad.
So I think that's
exactly as you say,
it's a lot more complicated
in many settings.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I just have a
question about the graphs.
What is the y-axis?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
It's the density.
It's the aggregates.
It adds up to 1.
So essentially,
it's a fraction--
think of this as the
fraction overall--
it's essentially--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that are greater than 1?
FRANK SCHILBACH: It's
the PDF, essentially.
It adds up its
aggregates up to it to 1.
So another version of that would
be just a fraction of people.
AUDIENCE: But you can't have a
fraction that's larger than 1.
I'm confused.
FRANK SCHILBACH: No,
this is not the fraction.
This is the PDF, right?
AUDIENCE: That's the PDF.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, exactly.
It's the PDF that's
essentially aggregates to 1.
But you could relabel
this and essentially
look at the fraction of people.
The graph would
exactly look the same.
Maybe you should just do that.
So second, let's talk a little
bit about time preferences.
So one interesting example--
and in some sense, I think
one of the things we'd
like to encourage you
in behavioral economics
or in psychology and economics
is look around in the world
and think about
what's weird or what
kind of things in the
world can be explained
with behavioral
economics, the things
that we see in the world?
And here's one example of that,
which is just a weird thing,
if you think about it.
So there's this
bet that's called--
there's these betting agencies.
And one of these
bets is where dieters
can bet on their own
weight loss success.
And they often lose.
So how does this work?
There's William Hill, which
is a sports betting agency,
and they offer all
sorts of weird bets.
And one of them
apparently is also
some somewhat
unusual wagers, where
people are allowed to bet
on their own weight loss.
And in fact, they do that.
But they often lose
while doing this.
Now why is this a weird bet?
What's weird about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you
have control technically
over the outcome [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
So if you had
perfect self-control,
and if you had perfect
foresight, in some sense,
if you understood what
your preferences are,
and you have plans for
the next month or two--
of course, there's
unexpected things
that could happen-- but if you
understood your preferences
well and had perfect
self-control,
you would know that either
you can lose weight,
and then you would win the bet.
Or you would not lose weight,
but then you would not even
start the bet in
the first place.
But here, over 80% of
betters, in fact, lose.
So now how do we
think about that?
How do we explain this behavior?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes?
FRANK SCHILBACH: And
so more specifically,
what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
starting tomorrow.
But when tomorrow comes,
they do not [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
But there's two things
going on, potentially.
So one is of
control, in the sense
of I have low self control.
I like eating donuts.
And I like eating donuts a lot.
So I'm not going to lose
any weight any time soon.
Can that explain that
behavior by itself?
Or what else do we need?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A part of it.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Oh sorry, yeah?
AUDIENCE: That's
part of the answer.
The other part is I'm
stopping [INAUDIBLE]
tomorrow [INAUDIBLE]
that I want to lose
some weight [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So what you need is some
form of naivete or optimism
in a sense of
saying, maybe today
I know I really like donuts.
But tomorrow I will
just eat lots of salad.
And so in some sense, there's
this overoptimism naivete,
where people are
essentially naive
about their future preferences.
Plus there needs to be some
form of self control problems.
And that combination leads
to these kinds of bets.
So one part is
self-control problems.
The second part is a
naivete overconfidence.
Putting these together could
get some people to essentially
engage in these kinds of bets.
Is there some other
motivation why
you would engage in this bet?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
actually be [INAUDIBLE]??
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So it could be that in
some sense, I'm just--
so one explanation is--
I think this is a
really great deal.
Somebody offers me
this great deal.
I'm just going to
gluon some weight.
And I'm going to make
a bunch of money.
And then afterwards, I guess
I'll eat a bunch of donuts.
So I don't really necessarily
need to want to lose weight.
I just think it's a great deal.
So that's overconfidence
about my self-control.
Then I engage in the bet.
It turns out actually I
don't have self-control.
And I lose the money
and eat lots of donuts.
Now the second thing that
you're saying is actually,
I might actually be aware
of my self-control problem.
And so I might actually
understand that I
have a self-control problem.
Now I'm engaging in this
bet because as it turns out,
on average, I guess there's
a 20% chance of me actually
succeeding.
And perhaps the bet itself might
help me in achieving that goal.
So that's essentially
some form of a commitment
device, where engaging in that
is helping me lose weight.
I might actually know.
And there's a
question of are you
fully sophisticated or perhaps
partially or fully naive?
In some sense, I might know that
there's a good chance that I
might actually lose the money.
But it might be worth for me
actually engaging in the bet
because the expected
value of losing weight
might be higher than the
loss of money overall.
So I think we said all
there is to say here.
So essentially there's either--
again either people are just
overconfidence or naive.
Second one is people might
want to set themselves
incentives to lose weight.
Again you need some
naivete and a sense of--
or some stochasticity
or something.
Otherwise it couldn't be--
otherwise you would
only engage in the bet
if that's actually helpful.
So it needs to be--
some people either--
it's stochastic,
or they're partially naive.
In some sense they think
there's a chance it'll work.
But in fact, maybe they
overestimate how high
the chance of succeeding is.
So overall what this
reflects is there's
a conflict between short-run
and long-run plans.
There's actually
two things going on.
One is what you want
in the short run might
be different from what
you wanted the long run.
Second one is you might have
imperfect foresight about that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Were people allowed
to bet they would gain weight?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Say that?
AUDIENCE: Were people allowed
to bet they would gain weight?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Actually, I don't know.
You could try.
I actually don't know.
But I think that's
probably easier to do.
So maybe they wouldn't
accept the bets.
Or your quota would be worse.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could there also
be a change in utility,
where you [INAUDIBLE] I'll
get-- if I lose 10 pounds,
I'll get $500.
But over time, you're
like, oh, eating
is actually-- changing my
eating habits is Oh, working out
is difficult. So now
I'd rather pay the $500
but not have to lose
the weight because I'm
no longer as interested.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
She's saying in
some sense, there's
some learning
uncertainty involved.
Yeah, I think that could be
the case for some people.
You would think in
over 80% of people,
they know their
preferences by now.
So a lot of behaviors--
and I have the same I'm
chronically overoptimistic about
when I get up in the morning.
Every night, I'm sort of,
tomorrow at 7:00, I'll get up.
And I'll exercise and write a
poem and so on and so forth.
And then that never happens.
So I think you say,
there is potentially
uncertainty about the world.
And you might just not know
how hard losing weight is,
in this example.
There's plenty of examples,
which we're going to show you,
where people over and over
make the same choices that
seem to be not optimal.
But you think people should have
all the information they need.
And people should have
learned over time.
But I think part of that is
some explanation, potentially,
is learning.
That's exactly right.
So then what we have done here--
in our survey, we asked
you two questions.
One was, how often do you
think you should be exercising?
The other one is, how often
do you, in fact, exercise?
These actually
look quite similar.
There seems to be one person
who thinks they should,
and they actually do
exercise 50 times a month--
[LAUGHTER]
--which is very impressive.
I don't know whether
you were truthful.
You know who you are.
So if you plot this
against each other,
what do you essentially
see is quite a bit of mass
below the 45 degree
axis, which is
to say there's a
bunch of people who
say they should be exercising
more than they actually do.
And that's a typical
pattern in the world.
Lots of people
think in the future,
they should be doing things
or more virtuous things.
In the future, they
would like to be
a better and more virtuous,
more healthy person
than they actually are.
So if you had to choose for next
month or next week or the like,
you would choose lots of
virtuous and good things
for yourself.
But then if you had to
choose for right now,
that might not actually happen.
And that leads to this
discrepancy between people's
desires and the
actual behaviors,
which we're going to then
study and try and understand.
And then the broad question
there, then is to say,
given that that's
the case, do people
understand their behavior?
Are they sophisticated?
And are they engaging in
certain commitment devices
or certain behaviors
that might help them
overcome those types of issues?
So at the source
of this conflict
is essentially what we call
present bias, which essentially
is manifested in what we ask you
about as well, which is ask you
two questions about a choice
between $100 in cash two weeks
from now versus $x
in 54 weeks from now.
If you think about 52
versus 54 weeks from now,
that's really far in the future.
And two weeks early or late
really don't make a difference.
And most people would probably
say something close to 100.
If I instead ask you
right now, would you
like to have $100 versus
in two weeks from now,
a lot more people say
they'd rather have $100 now.
Or they take like a
lower amount right now
than $100 and the
future, essentially
because right now, they
put a lot of weight
into the immediate present.
And that's what we refer
to as present bias.
Essentially people put
disproportional very high
weight on the president,
compared to anything
that's in the future.
And so when you look at that,
it's a little bit noisy.
And the question
is not quite ideal
because in some sense, what
I really would like to do
is ask you about 52 weeks
from now and 54 weeks from now
and then wait for a
year and then ask you
the exact same question again.
Now I can't really wait
for you to do that.
So in some sense,
the circumstances
in a year from now I might
be quite different from what
they are now.
You might be richer, or more
educated, wiser, and so on.
But for what it's
worth, it does seem
to be the case that
when you ask people
about $100 in 52 weeks
versus 54 weeks from now,
the distribution is
very close to 100.
Essentially you don't
care very much about
whether you get $100 in 52
weeks versus 54 weeks from now.
If you look at like
$100 now versus
$100 in two weeks
from now, I have
to pay you a higher amount
in two weeks from now
to get you indifferent
between now and two weeks
from now, which is saying
like you care more about today
versus two weeks from now.
Your discount rate between
today and two weeks from now
is higher than it is from
52 versus 54 weeks from now.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering how you
could distinguish
this time preference
and expectation of this.
For example, if
you offer money now
is more certain than
two weeks from now,
[INAUDIBLE] I do
not see you again.
But if I look at 52 versus
54, they are both uncertain.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So just to repeat the
question, the question
is what about risk?
So if I ask you $100
now, and I give you
$100 bill, and
say-- or some money
in the future, who knows
whether I'm going to show up
and actually give you the money.
And there's reason
to be skeptical.
I will be here in two weeks.
Don't worry.
So there's a bunch
of experiments
that, in fact, try to deal
with that fairly carefully.
So they will do things like in
some experiments with students,
they give the
professor's office name.
They have the phone
number, the business card--
they even give checks that
are sent automatically.
So people try to deal with that.
It's a great question.
In fact, there's
lots of research
in that to try to do that.
Some people said,
this present bias
is actually not
real that you find
in these types of experiments.
But then people have been
very careful in trying
to disentangle risk
from time preferences.
And they find essentially even
if you try to minimize risk
as much as possible
in those experiments,
present bias seems to persist
in those kinds of choices.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
about the reasoning
or being indifferent between
$100 now and less than $100
in the future.
FRANK SCHILBACH: You have to
ask your classmates about that.
It could be that in
some sense, you say--
if you, for example, say you
know that you tend to waste
money in certain situations--
maybe you're really tired
today, and you're
just going to say,
I'm going to waste the
money on hamburgers--
you might say maybe in a week
from now, things are different.
I think there's
lots of explanation
that you can come up with.
Again, you have to
ask your classmates
what they were thinking.
If anybody has an explanation,
please let us know.
I think one broad
bottom line from this
in these kinds of experiments,
you see a lot of behavior
that looks--
there's lots of
potential anomalies.
There's lots of
noise, essentially,
in some of those kinds of data.
In aggregate,
things often look--
the patterns emerge.
But lots of people
make choices that are
in fact hard to rationalize.
And we try and look
at aggregate patterns.
Most of these things
are systematic.
But there's some people,
they're on the very left.
Maybe these are just
mistakes, for example,
or they just misunderstood
the question.
Or there's typos and
so on and so forth.
So let me summarize here.
So people tend to be fairly
patient for far-off decisions.
So in the future,
you're actually
quite patient between
stuff that happens
between a year from
now, two years from now,
five years from now.
People invest all sorts of
things for the far away future.
But when it comes to
immediately relevant decisions,
people tend to be
quite impatient.
You care a lot
about right now what
happens, the next maybe
day or the next few hours.
You care a lot about that
much more than a week
or two or even a year from now.
So there's then two broad
questions to begin to look at.
One is evidence of
those kinds of conflicts
between the current and
future selves in terms
of short-run desires
and long-run goals.
And we can try and
find evidence of that.
Second, we're going to look
at whether and how people
predict their future
utility and behavior.
And that's a general pattern
in behavioral economics
and psychology and
economics, is to say actually
the fact that people have
present bias itself is not
a huge problem in the sense
of causing welfare losses
or making people unhappy,
as long as people
are sophisticated.
So as long as I know I
have self control problems,
and I'm fully aware of them, I
can set my decision environment
or my choices such
that I can actually
mitigate a lot of these
biases, in part because I can
buy certain commitment devices.
I can set alarm
clocks and all sorts
of things that might help
me improve my behavior.
The problem comes from naivete.
And then to say, if I have
self-control problems,
and I'm naive on
top of that, then
I might get really
screwed because I think,
I'm going to go do
stuff in the future.
I'll do it in the future.
And so on-- and then
the future comes.
And surprise, I'm
still present bias
and have like self
control problems.
So if I think that I'm have
more self control than actually
have, that might cause a lot
of bad behaviors or problems
because I make mistakes that are
then hard to fix in the future.
That's a general pattern
about behavioral economics.
Similar issues-- for example,
you think about memory,
if I have imperfect
memory, that's of course,
potentially a problem.
But I can fix it in some sense.
I can set myself reminders.
I can help other people have
them remind me and so on.
I can set my
decision environments
that I can account
for imperfect memory.
The problem comes if
I'm overconfident.
If I think I can
remember everything ,
I talked to people and never
take notes and [INAUDIBLE]
I'll remember, but
then an hour later,
I've forgotten everything,
that really needs to problems.
And again it's not
the bias itself
in terms of having imperfect
cognitive function or the like,
but rather the
overconfidence of the same
that often leads to welfare
losses or making people unhappy
or making inferior choices.
So let me talk about
beliefs then for a bit.
So a broad set of
beliefs or-- sorry,
were there any other
questions about preferences?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
for present bias,
is it in general symmetrical
compared to loss versus pain?
Do people prefer to lose in the
future rather than to lose now?
And is it [INAUDIBLE]
in general?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
We'll talk about that.
In fact, in some sense, people
tend to-- so essentially people
like to have gains
in the present
and losses in the future.
In some sense-- think
of it like this.
You put more weight
on the present utility
than you put on
the future utility.
How do you do that?
You want to have more
gains and fewer losses
or negative things going on.
That is not to say that loss
aversion always happens--
so loss aversion as a
concept of gains and losses,
you are loss averse
in the present,
and you also loss
of in the future.
But if you could
pick, would you rather
have a gain in the
present or a loss--
or a gain or loss in the
present versus in the future,
you would tend to
say, I'd rather
have the gain now and the
loss in the future, precisely
because you overweigh,
essentially, the present period
or utility.
I don't know if that--
but we'll talk about that.
So let me talk about now beliefs
and information updating.
So one very basic question
that I think we ask you
and that's a classic question
that people, like Kahneman
and Tversky and so
on would often ask,
which is essentially
the question,
suppose 100 people have HIV.
We have a test for HIV
that's 99% accurate.
This means that if
a person has HIV,
the test returns a positive
result with 99% probability.
And if the person
does not have HIV,
it returns a negative
result with 99% probability.
If a person's HIV test
came back positive,
what's the probability
that she has HIV?
Now that's a very
straightforward question,
that there's a clear
correct answer.
If you know Bayes' rule,
you can essentially
just calculate that.
I'm sure somewhere in
statistics, et cetera,
people have taught you that.
Now 22% of this class
would have answered 99%.
That's usually
the classic what's
called base rate neglect.
For what it's worth,
you guys are much better
than previous years.
I don't know why that is.
But maybe people get
smarter over time.
But still this is MIT.
So if 20% of MIT
students get this wrong,
surely the fraction in the
general population who gets
that wrong is a lot higher.
And the typical explanation
is that there's what's
called base rate neglect.
The logic is
something like this.
A positive person will probably
receive a positive result.
If she's tested positive, she's
likely to be HIV positive.
And then that's 99%.
Now that's a very sort of
natural and easy answer.
In particular if you only
had like five or 10 seconds
to answer this question,
that's a natural response
many people would make.
Usually the fraction
of people would
say 99% would be a lot
higher or maybe half or more.
In previous years, I
think it was about half.
And very few people,
in fact, would
give the correct answer of 50%.
And the mistake
here is essentially
what's called sort
of base rate neglect,
is to ignore the fact that
the population, the base rate,
is in fact, very low.
It's only 1%.
And you should
condition on that when
you try to solve this problem.
So here's what you see.
So 50 is the correct answer.
If I remember right.
But there's lots of
spread around this.
And the fraction of
people who get it right
is maybe 50% or even
lower than that.
So now in some sense,
you can look at this
and look into the
answer as like 50%.
The key part is not is
this a specific problem
and some people
maybe misunderstood
and so on and so forth.
The point here is that this is
actually a fairly basic problem
in terms of probability theory.
This is a very simple
problem to solve
in a sense of if you think
about real problems you need
to solve in the world, the
world is way more complicated
than that.
However, even
among MIT students,
something like half
of the students,
when given several minutes at
least to think about this--
and I don't know how
much time you took--
but when given quite a bit
of time to think about it--
get the answer wrong.
That means essentially,
in many other decisions
you have to act
much faster, people
don't think about these
things that much, people
have not taken statistics.
People have not taken
math, and so on.
And so the fraction
of people who
would get these
very basic problems
is probably much
higher, let alone
much more complicated problems.
So broadly speaking,
these problems are hard.
Often what we do when we have
cognitively demanding tasks,
we tend to have sort of
quick intuitive shortcuts.
In some sense, think about
the problems are really hard.
We try to simplify and
make it easier for us.
We give intuitive answers
to those types of questions.
These intuitive answers
are actually often not bad.
They're actually pretty
close in many situations.
But often they systematically
leads to incorrect answers.
And essentially then,
there's a whole field
of essentially cognitive
psychology and so on that
tries to think about what
kind of biases arise.
And in particular,
Kahneman and Tversky, who--
Danny Kahneman, a
psychologist who
got the Nobel
Prize in economics,
with the experiments--
and you may have read
Thinking Fast and Slow--
with their experiments,
essentially
demonstrated a large number
of those kinds of anomalies
and biases in
people's cognition,
if you want, in
terms of heuristics
that they use for these kinds of
probability and other problems.
And these are systematic biases.
These are not so subtle
random mistakes that
are added to people's choices.
People systematically
in systematic ways
deviate from optimal choices
or correct calculations.
And the question is,
can we understand
these systematic
biases better and then
try to explain behavior
systematically?
And if we understood
these mistakes better,
then we could sort of
potentially fix the mistakes
and improve people's
decision making.
There's another question
that worked reasonably well--
but MIT is a little bit
of special population--
which is the question
of overconfidence.
And it's a little bit hard to
elicit with a simple survey.
So what we are asking you about,
what's the probability of you
yourself would earn
a lot of money,
versus what's the probability
of what students in your class
would make this type of money?
Now if you think about these
two questions, at least
under some assumptions,
they should add up
to the same number.
So essentially if you
aggregate over everybody,
if the people's
expectations are correct,
they should add up to
the same number, at least
under some assumptions.
Usually they do not.
The difference is
actually relatively small.
MIT is a little bit of a
special population in a sense.
If you look at like
surveys across the world,
for example, if you think about
driving behavior in the world,
something like
90%, 95% of drivers
think that better than
the median driver.
Lots of people think they're
smarter than the median person
and so on.
There's lots of evidence of
overconfidence in the world.
So MIT to some degree has
actually an opposite issue,
which is under confidence.
When you look at
student surveys at MIT,
there's quite a bit of
evidence that essentially--
and I'll show you this,
in fact, in class--
about the typical
MIT student thinks
they're worse than the
average MIT student.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--there seems to be some
overconfidence here.
But it's, in fact, not
particularly strong.
So there you can see there's
some over and under confidence.
Perhaps there's a little
bit of overconfidence here.
But in fact, it's fairly weak.
But overall as a
pattern in the world,
there seems to be quite
a bit of overconfidence
in many situations.
And then the question
is, does overconfidence
lead to bad outcomes?
If you're overconfident
about certain situations,
then are you going to fail
a lot because you do stuff
that is too difficult for you?
If you're under
confident, you might not
engage in certain
behaviors and not
try things that would
be good for you.
In fact, Maddie, who is
currently traveling--
one of your TAs--
has some very
interesting work in India
about women being under
confident and thus
not trying to
convince the household
members or their husbands
and so on to try and work
in the labor market.
And that leads to lower
labor supply, earnings,
and so on and so forth.
So if you are under
confident, you
might not try certain things
that might be good for you.
And then the problem
is if you never try it,
you might actually
never learn about it.
If you never even
try it yourself,
then you might never
even fail or learn
that you might be
actually able to do that.
So these potential traps
of under confidence--
or if you're overconfident,
you might just
fail because you try I think
it's actually not good for you.
And then there's other issues
about motivated beliefs
that I discussed this
already last time, which
is the idea that you might be
overconfident, not because you
actually necessarily
believe or deeply
believe what you
like to believe,
but in fact, because it
just makes you feel good
about the world
or about yourself.
So I might not actually-- if
you really ask me I'm a better
driver than the median
driver, I might not actually
necessarily--
if you make me think
about it, I might actually
agree that that's not the case.
But I like to think
about I do things well.
So in some sense, I
might just say yes
because it makes me
feel good about myself.
So essentially
overconfidence could
be driven by motivated beliefs.
And that's another topic that
we're going to try and study.
So now, as I said, there
are preferences and beliefs
that we study.
So in some sense, preferences
about what you want,
beliefs about what you
think the world is like.
Now putting this
together, as I said,
people's choices should
be entirely determined.
But that tends to
be not the case.
And one classic survey that's
a survey question or a version
of a survey question
that Richard Thaler--
who won the Nobel Prize
recently in economics--
has asked a bunch of people,
which is the following.
The question is,
imagine that you're
about to purchase
an iPad for $500.
The salesman tells you that
you can get the exact same--
good in a nearby
location for $15 off.
You would need to walk
for 30 minutes in total.
Would you go to the other store?
So you look at this question.
If an economist looks
at this, the question
is, there's some
cost of walking.
It's tedious to walk.
Maybe it's raining, maybe not.
And then you have
some value of time.
Either your value of time for 30
minutes is below or above $15.
If the answer is your
value of time is higher,
you're not going to walk.
If your answer is the
value of time is lower,
you're going to walk.
Case closed.
You're done.
And you know your preferences.
And you have all the
information you need.
Now I'm asking you
a related question,
which is in fact, the
exact same questions,
if you think about
it, except for what's
different is it's about an
iPad versus an iPad case.
I'm asking you the
exact same question,
which is the question about
would you walk for half an hour
for $15?
So again either
your value of time
is above or below
$15 for 30 minutes.
If the answer is
yes, you should say--
if your value of
time is higher, you
should say no to both questions.
If the value of
time is lower, you
should say yes to
both questions.
But notice here that questions
are exactly the same.
The only thing that's
changing is essentially
the value of the item.
Now why might people still
say different things?
Or what's potentially
affecting behavior here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
So we're thinking in
relative terms, which
is to say the $15 seems pretty
small when it compares to $500.
That's to say, $500
is a lot of money.
So if you spend $500,
you might as well--
whatever, $15 more or less,
it doesn't really matter.
When you spend $30, $15
is like half of that.
It's a lot of money.
So you get like $15 off.
That would be a really
great deal to get.
But when you think
about now going back--
and this is I guess when
you go back to recitation,
look at utility maximization--
there's no place for these
relative considerations.
When you maximize
utility, it would
be like the utility of this
potentially consumption items
and so on.
These are all in absolute terms.
And either money makes you
happy or not or walking
makes you unhappy.
There's no relative
comparison here overall.
Yet what seems to
be really important
is all these relative concerns.
And then you look
at this question.
This is I think one
of the question that's
the most robust I've found
in any of the surveys I did.
This always works, essentially.
People are much more likely
to-- or say, at least,
they're much more likely
to walk for an iPad case
than they are for
an actual iPad.
There's various reasons why
you might say, in this case,
maybe if you have an iPad,
you buy an iPad for $300--
whatever I said-- you might
have a lot more money.
And so you're richer
and so on and so forth.
And maybe that can
explain the results.
There's 10 different
versions of these question
that all have different flavors.
And essentially this
result is extremely robust.
People tend to think in relative
terms and not in absolute terms
when making these
kinds of choices.
And their choices are extremely
malleable to those kinds
of comparisons.
Any questions about that?
Yeah
AUDIENCE: So how about
joint evaluations?
So if you were to ask people
that you would buy this iPad,
you get the $15 off and
also for the same iPad case,
you get $15 off.
And if you go there and
buy both, you get $30 off.
So do you think the same
behavior to walk would
[INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: I think
what people in some ways
do in their heads, they do
essentially what fraction
do you get off in some ways?
And if you then bought both,
I guess that would be--
I don't know what the
prices where-- it would be I
guess $530.
And then you get--
I think it would probably
be somewhere in between.
The behavior would probably be
quite similar to the iPad thing
overall because you would have--
I think what people do
in their mind is to say,
I'm spending already x
dollars-- in case $500 or $530--
now does the $15 look large
or small compared to that?
$15 looks really
large compared to $30.
So let's just walk.
And I might as well do it
and get a really good deal.
I get 50% off.
When you have $500 or $530,
the $15 seems really small.
That's not really a great deal.
So why bother doing it?
Let's just spend it all anyway.
But of course, the
issue is $15, and you're
going to use that $15
for something else,
presumably not just iPads.
And then you should give
essentially the same answer.
There's some very
interesting evidence
I'm going to show you at the
very end of the class, which is
about poor versus rich people.
So there's some evidence
that [INAUDIBLE] and others
have done that do exactly these
kinds of relative thinking
comparisons with rich
people and with poor people.
And what you find
there overall is
that rich people do
this a lot, poor people
actually not so much.
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: No.
It's for the same amount.
They keep the amounts the same.
AUDIENCE: They value it a
lot more than rich people.
FRANK SCHILBACH: So
they value it more.
Yes, that's right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because rich
people have more money,
they can more afford to
spend less time thinking
about the $15 and
therefore, might
make more of a snap
judgment [INAUDIBLE]
poor people might deliberate
about it for a minute.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
Exactly.
So in some sense--
so there's two
different explanations.
One is in a way, like a
classical explanation,
is to say there's
certain amounts of money
that for the rich, it
just doesn't matter.
If you have a million dollars,
why walk anyway and whatever?
I just don't pay attention.
And in some sense, I make
them certain mistakes.
But the mistakes that
really not very costly.
It's just that I
don't really care.
I might make mistakes.
But it's really not an issue
because I'm rich anyway.
There's another view, and
that is to say, for the poor,
at a daily basis, they
evaluate something like $15--
for the poor, they
know what $15 is worth.
For them, it's not a
comparison to $500 or whatever.
$15 is a meal for your family.
It's about the difference
between your child being hungry
versus getting food and so on.
So then for them, $1 is $1.
And they're less
affected by these framing
and other choices.
But that's one of the most
interesting evidence in poverty
research, where
people essentially
try to understand how do
people's monetary choices--
or how are they affected
by these framings?
And the view overall is that
the poor might, in fact,
be more rational in some sense,
in the sense of less swayed
by framing and
other choices that
might lead to
inconsistent choices,
while the rich do
that a lot more.
And the downside
of that seems to be
that thinking a lot of
money, the poor then spend
a lot of cognitive
energy on thinking
about these monetary issues.
And that might lead you
to make worse decisions
in other domains of life.
You might have just
less cognitive function
or cognitive energy if
you want available--
or resources available for other
potentially important choices
in life.
And that's what we talk about
in the property development
section.
Then there was
another choice that we
did that usually tends to work.
And this is a very
interesting line
of research by Dan
Ariely and others,
which essentially
is about anchoring.
In some sense, looking
at this exposed,
I think the questions
were not quite right.
So the idea of
anchoring is to say,
if I set you a very
arbitrary anchor,
but let you think about
certain numbers, in this case,
it was the sum of
people's phone numbers.
Then essentially when you have
a high sum of phone numbers,
you willing to pay more.
If you have a sum
of phone numbers,
you're willing to pay less.
There's a bunch of
experiments actually done
at MIT with MBA students,
mostly, I have to say--
but MBA students mostly,
about Dan Ariely, who
used to be a faculty
member at MIT,
that a bunch of these
kinds of experiments
were essentially-- you
can anchor people fairly
arbitrarily.
And if you would make them
think about the last two
digits of their social
security number,
if that social security
number is high,
they're willing to
pay more for wine
than if the social
security number is low.
And this is also a real choice
that tends to be quite robust.
One problem with the experiment
that we're doing here
that didn't seem to show up--
in 2017 there was
more anchoring.
Here it doesn't seem like maybe
it's upward sloping, maybe not.
One problem here is
that the anchor-- if you
look at the values of the
anchor that we were setting,
they're actually pretty
low, they're essentially
between something
like 10 and 30,
while people's valuation tends
to be often a lot higher.
So maybe that's why it
potentially didn't work.
It could be that you guys
are less prone to anchoring.
But overall I think
the bottom line
is there's quite a bit
of evidence essentially
that when you anchor people,
that affects their choices.
And again of course, it
shouldn't affect your choice
at all.
When it makes you think about
your social security number,
a large or small numbers,
that should by no means
affect how much are
you're willing to pay
for a glass of water a bottle
of wine or anything else.
Yet there's a relatively
robust line of research
that shows that in
fact, that's the case.
And for example it seems
like, at least in 2017,
that was in fact going on.
Finally, I want to talk
to something briefly,
which is quite
interesting literature
in social psychology.
And it's this paper by
Darley & Batson, which
is a classic study in psychology
that studies helping behavior.
And broadly speaking, you can
think of social psychology
perhaps as a way of
thinking about how
do social circumstances
or your environments
affect your behavior
or your preferences?
And that's a deviation from
what economists think about.
Usually economists would say,
you have certain preferences.
You either want
to be nice or not.
Or you either want to eat
certain things or not.
It shouldn't depend that much
on your social environment.
And social psychology
studies in detail
are like how your choices
or behaviors-- in this case,
I guess helping behavior-- is
affected by your environment.
And so what they did is they
studied helping behavior.
These are Princeton
theology students
on their way to a seminar.
And they pass an
ostensibly injured man
slumped in a doorway,
coughing and groaning.
This is somebody
in the experiment.
So social psychology
studies are very
rich in creating
interesting environments.
So they had this
man who essentially
is looking very injured.
And they were looking
at determinants
of helping behavior.
So the question is, do
these theology students
stop and help this
man when they're
on the way to their seminar?
And they had three
different manipulations.
I should say very clearly this
with a very small sample alert,
the study is very small.
So there's some question--
does this replicate,
which is often
for several social psychology
studies, classic studies,
sample sizes are
relatively small.
So there are some questions
on how does it replicate?
But I think the point
broadly speaking,
is a good one, which is why
I'm telling you about this.
So what are the
three manipulations?
Three things.
One was they had a lecture
on the parable of the Good
Samaritan versus
some other content.
What is the Good
Samaritan parable?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's about
helping someone in need
on the side of the road?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So it's about essentially
this person who--
long story short,
there's a person
in need on the side of the road.
They're people who are from
the same area, the priests
and so on-- nobody is helping
because they're really busy.
And then the Samaritan comes,
who is an outcast in society
and so on.
And he's helping.
And the point is you
should help anybody
and so on, regardless
of background
and so on and so forth.
So the whole story is
essentially saying,
you should be helping somebody.
So there are these students
now who have been essentially--
they've been thinking
about this parable.
They've thinking about
helping behavior.
They're o supposed to
give essentially a lecture
about the parable of
the Good Samaritan.
In their mind, is
to think about,
you should be helping others.
So we determine that mindset in
[INAUDIBLE],, and then in fact,
to see the practical
version of that in life.
The question is, does
that affect behavior?
The second variation is
variation and time pressures,
just are people
in a hurry or not?
And the third one is
personality measures,
in particular religiosity.
So people are more
or less religious.
And you might think that that
also affects or determines
how much people are helping.
So now you can look at
which of those three things
matters for behavior.
Who thinks one is
most important?
What about two?
Three?
I set this up in some sense
maybe not the right way.
So it turns out two is,
in fact, as you said,
the most important thing.
The hurry condition,
essentially-- again,
it's a small sample.
But in no hurry,
about 60% of people
stopped, medium hurry, 45%.
Of people in a high hurry,
essentially nobody stops.
People essentially--
but the reason
they're worried about
coming to that seminar,
about the Good Samaritan,
and they're not
sort of particularly good
Samaritans themselves.
It turns out the personality
characteristics don't seem
to really predict behaviors.
And so what we learn from
that is that situations
can matter a great deal.
Now in some sense that's
very much consistent what
I was saying to you earlier,
about social influences
affect behavior, in some
sense, in the sense of you
care about others
in a way depends
a lot on your circumstances
in the sense of are you
observed or not or in
malleable situations.
But I think in sense,
here's like a choice that's
exactly the same choice.
You might either be nice or not.
But in some sense,
the value of time
seems to be quite
important here for people.
So people's choices in some
sense might actually be--
it's not like you are a
nice person versus not.
But in some
situations, you might
behave very nicely and friendly
and in others, not so much.
And that's a much more
fundamental problem
perhaps for economics or for
writing down utility functions
because essentially,
the issue is
that it's not even clear
what your social preference
parameter is.
It's not even clear are you
a nice person or not so much
a nice person because it depends
so much on your environment.
And people are shaped by
their environments overall.
So one thing they're going to
think about towards the end
of the class is to say,
people's-- it's not just that
their preferences or their
beliefs systematically deviate
in ways that we can quantify
from the classical model.
But in fact, it's the
case that they're actually
very volatile and maybe even
hard to elicit in some ways
because they're
changing so much.
And in fact, people might
not even know necessarily
their preferences.
Or their preferences are
just malleable in the sense
of they depend a lot on
circumstantial situations.
So then let me summarize
quickly what we discussed.
So I think one way--
and this is what
I was saying earlier-- one way
to think about this class is
one goal of this class is
really to get you to think
more and observe the world
more in a way through the lens
of economics, but also
through the lens of psychology
and economics.
That's to say you can think
about a lot of situations, how
people behave and try to
understand why they behave
in the ways they do.
And you often see certain
puzzles or certain behaviors
that don't look quite right.
It seems like people are sort
of making mistakes in some ways.
They seem to be sort of
erratic in various ways.
But often you can actually
put a lot of structure
in their behavior.
We can actually
understand systematically
through a certain
puzzle to a certain
[INAUDIBLE],, through
certain theories
or certain topics that we
discussed in class, what
people do and why they do that.
There's also similar
issues about firms.
When you think about when you
get credit card offers, when
you think about a sales item
and so on, when you think about
like pricing decisions
that firms make,
a lot of these pricing or
decisions that firms make
are actually thinking
very carefully
about the psychology
of consumers.
So essentially what
firms are doing,
they're trying to think
about potential-- what
they call behavioral biases
or issues that consumers have.
And when you think about
what do you see in the world,
often that makes
actually a lot of sense
through the lens of
psychology and economics
or behavioral economics.
So you can think about
yourself or others
when you see certain products.
Think about how does this relate
to the content of the course
that we have?
And I think that's
a general lesson.
So what we try to do
in the course, in part,
is think about individual
choices and some theories
in economics and psychology, but
in particular think about how
do these series and relate
to real world outcomes,
how can we perhaps apply them
to situations in the world
and potentially improve choices?
So here's broadly where we are.
As I said, you're going
to talk about preferences
for the next few weeks, in
particular time preferences
and self control.
As I said, a lot of that has
to do with procrastination,
including for problem sets.
As I said, the problem
set will come probably
something around Monday.
Here's the reading
for next week.
This is on the course website.
Please read Frederick O'Donoghue
2002 sections 1, as well as
4.1 to 5.1.
Thank you very much.